it was 5 55 in the morning and much of
the nipro was asleep
only to be woken to this
one of three explosions that rocked the
city
caught on surveillance camera
oksana didn't hear the air raid sirens
but the force of the blast shattered the
windows and her ceiling collapsed
she lives on the fourth floor of an
apartment block facing a shoe factory an
apparent target of russian missiles
we didn't expect anything in nepal there
are no military facilities around the
russians were saying that they would
only target military infrastructure here
there are only residential blocks the
school and the kindergarten windows were
hit
the ukrainian military says the rockets
were launched from the donetsk region in
territory controlled by the
russian-backed separatists this is the
first time this city has been targeted
since the beginning of the war now that
will have a huge impact because so far
nepal has been a transit point for
people fleeing other areas in eastern
ukraine that were under heavy
bombardment
the immediate impact long queues outside
the train station
people standing for hours in sub-zero
temperature
patiently waiting to escape despite the
fear of another attack
katja took the decision to pack up and
leave as soon as she heard the early
morning explosions
it's a nightmare nato's not doing enough
they should close the sky they should do
more
many of those standing here had fled the
horrors of war once before their home
times already destroyed now seeking safe
refuge again
irina and her two children drove out of
kharkiv after russian jet fighters flew
over her neighborhood for days and the
shelling became closer and louder
this conflict has thrown her family
apart
zolensky won't do what russia expects
from him so we don't know what awaits us
of course ukraine will not compromise
my son also says no we were living in
hell in kharkiv for a week and now we
hate russia although we have many
relatives there
many of those leaving will join the 2.5
million refugees that have already
crossed into neighboring countries
while those staying wonder what's next
al jazeera linnipro